Different types of camera
So far we've just considered the case of perspective
projection. It's the sort of image that is formed
by a simple lens and the same sort of optics
as we have in our own eyes. But there are
many many different sorts of cameras and different
sorts of lenses.
They don't necessarily perform perspective
projection. In this particular case, we're
looking at a fish eye lens image. A fish eye
lens here has got a very very wide field of
view. If we look at the image captured by
the fish eye lens, we notice a few things.
Most importantly we note that the straightness
of line is not preserved. So we see on top
of the laptop on the side of the coke can,
these are no longer straight lines. They appear
to be curves because this is not a perspective
projection. Lenses work by refraction.
That is they bend the rays of light that are passing through them.
Another way we can do this is by reflection.
We use curved mirrors instead of lenses in
order to bend the light rays. Here is an
example again from the drawings of Isaac
Newton of his early reflecting telescope.
Sometimes very very big lenses are actually
made by combinations of shaped mirrors and
lenses.
These sort of hybrid imaging systems are referred
to as catadioptrics. This is derived from
the Greek word dioptrics for refraction and
catoptrics for reflection.
Another type of imaging system again on this
catadioptric model is a panoramic lens. You
can see it quite clearly here. What we have
down the bottom is a fairly standard camera
with a lens in front of it. And then there
is a stalk which holds a parabolic mirror.
So the camera is actually looking at the parabolic
mirror.
This arrangement allows us to create panoramas.
So the raw panorama, what the camera actually
sees, is shown here on the bottom right. We
see a very very distorted view of the world.
Because we know the mathematics of this image
formation process we can unwrap the image
and that is what we use to create the panorama
shown at the top.
What we note with this panoramic image once
again is that straight lines are not preserved.
They appear to be very very seriously distorted.